ça s'est passé samedi 17 mars 2012 donc
après une demi-heure de
deux cars donc donc le jeu le chauffeur
a quitté la voie express donc il roulait
très vite
il ya quelqu'un qui a crié dans le car
il ya du coup je me suis retourné et
j'étais côté fenêtre et j'ai vu des
panneaux de signalisation qu'a indiqué
qu'un virage dangereux arriver bon j'ai
compris tout de suite ce qui allait se
passer étant donné la vitesse à laquelle
on roule et donc je me suis protégé
protégées dont le visage
est donc après il ya beaucoup de il y
avait beaucoup de bruit de hurlements
ans a cédé ya des bruits que j'entends
toujours aujourd'hui ça fait deux ans et
demi
après ma tête a cogné le sol pour moi
ç'a duré une éternité
je tiendrais pantin je maîtrisais plus
rien
et je pensais mais deux petites filles
et ça fait qu'il fallait que je tienne
mon
temps après le car c'est à ce enfin
arrêtez
donc là ces gens l'impression qu'il ya
que tout s'est arrêté à ce moment là
c'est j'entendais plus rien
je nommais où j'étais arrivé il y avait
des débris sur moi je t'ai recouverte de
débris il y avait des morceaux de verre
partout de la terre
donc
je n'entendais plus mon mari je me sens
rendu compte rapidement que j'avais mon
bras cassé
là je me sens rendue compte que j'avais
plus ma main
donc ça c'est un moment qui a tjrs
atroce
donc j'ai commencé à hurler et des mois
chercher ma main ce que j'avais très
bien qu'il fallait qu'on la retrouve
très vite pour qu'elles puissent rire
est très implantée
sur les injures les journées et je me
suis dit quand je vais tout c'est les
briques ce serait un vrai miracle delà
de la retrouver
alors mes filles je les ai vu quelques
jours après parce que je suis resté
quelques jours dans
ou à je trouve plus mes mots servent
donc je vous ai vu trois jours je crois
trois quatre jours après donc dans un
premier temps et mon mari en a décidé de
ne pas parler de la peur de ma main
parce que j'étais très marquée
au niveau du visage
du coup là je les vois encore rentré
dans la chambre d'hôpital
son entrée tout doucement en observant s
étaient très inquiètes
et c'est un moment pour moi qui à la
fois heureux parce que je les retrouvais
est à la fois qui a qui est très dur
parce que ça fait peur de moi donc à
l'homme
elles sont présentées le tour du lit you
moi j'avais qu'une hâte c'était les les
embrasser mais les serrer contre moi
bon je comprenais à son petit donc ans
est arrivé à ma plus jeune avait que
trois ans et demi mais il m'a grande six
ans mon corps va ravoir leur plein de
bobos comme elle disait sur le visage ça
les a
ça les a bien marqué
donc voilà dans un premier temps on a
dit à une longue et comme ça il faudra
mesure on va s'en sont approchés
et c'est un autre jour que
que je leur ai expliqué que
que voilà je commencé par dire que
j'avais mon bras qui avait été cassée et
que j'avais perdu ma ma
c'est un moment qui me restera à vie
d'ailleurs tous ces moments là
mais ma dernière m'a demandé mais maman
ta main va repousser c'est comme les
cheveux comme les ongles je suis trop ça
mignon il ya à la fois très dur parce
que c'est seulement c'est tenir ça
pouvait être vrai ce serait magnifique
il ya encore de bons moments
j'ai souhaité participer à ce tournage
pour sensibiliser les gens pour
afin qu'ils prennent conscience d'un
excellent vitesse pour entraîner de
grosses séquelles pour eux mêmes et
aussi pour les personnes qui se trouvent
face à ces personnes qui qui font par
exemple un excès de vitesse et qui nous
regardent m'ont dit ça a été mon corps
donc moi j'ai perdu à mama dans un
accident de la circulation qui est dû
annuler un excès de vitesse ils n'ont
lectrices du véhicule donc voilà ma vie
à chambouler ce jour l'ordre il faudrait
vraiment que que les gens prennent
conscience comme
les conséquences que cela peut avoir